as you look at you darvish year three of
a six-year deal and
he's starting to show cub fans why they
signed him
it's on the inside corner and a
strikeout starts tonight so guard didn't
like the call
garcia waits here comes a 2-2 from
darvish
struck him out two strikeouts in the
first inning for darvish a runner left
on
lead off double by horner rizzo advanced
him to third with a ground out
and now a ground ball left side play
is made at first and to score his horner
with
good base running and the cubs jump on
top
one to nothing on a double two ground
balls and this is like
baseball 1981 style
fred anderson brings it and schwarber
shoots one
into left center field at the wall it's
gone
kyle schwarber goes deep into left
center field hits number three
on the year and the cubs lead it two
nothing here in the second
and john whatever the scouting report is
on brett anderson you have to believe
it's trying to jump on the first pitch
schwarber does it
any homers one out nobody on here's
garcia
here's a one-two that's another
strikeout
six on the night and with one out nobody
on
here is gamble that's strike three at 96
on the outside
corner strikeout number seven sixth
inning
no hits for milwaukee here's the two
two and a strikeout that's number eight
with one out nobody on casting hira
[Music]
[Applause]
no hits through six one down cubs still
lead
two to nothing sixth inning and here's
ian half hamp drives one toward right
center field on the run garcia can't get
it that balls back toward the wall
short hopping the vines cone ferris
heading to third he's getting the green
light here comes the relay the throat of
the plate there's going to be a play the
slide
he's safe and going the throat is he in
great coaching by will cannibal great
slide at the plate by contreras
ian half with an rbi double goes to
third on the throw and the cubs now lead
three to nothing
half is 90 feet away one out the batter
is boating line drive into left field at
base hit another run is in
coming in the score ian half one scoring
single david bode cubs lead four
nothing avasail garcia leads it off
seventh inning another 02. a strikeout
that's
10. and now it's justin's smoke
here's one rocketed deep into right
field
back at the track at the wall it is
gone a home run off the bat of justin
smoke the no
hitter is gone the shutout is gone he
hits his
second of the season and this is a
three-run ball game
as the brewers are on the board in the
seventh finally uh
milwaukee brewer hitter was able to hit
a breaking ball or an off-speed pitch in
the middle of the plate it did not
have the late action that everyone else
has
and that's got to feel good for the
brewers to get on the board not only to
get a hit but get on the board with that
hit
and with a count of one and two
97 for strikeout number 11.
now let's go for two hit a rocket out to
right caught by souza back in the
fourth inning and his left side
what a play and got it
that was bodhi who went to his right he
was the only guy over there john smolton
with his momentum carrying him toward
the dugout through a strike
outstanding play the shift of course
what you're talking about and he did
right
off balance but right on target yellows
can run so
big out now one out away from the cubs
extending their best record in baseball
here's garcia two outs brewers trailing
by three
that is hit hard and into left field
down toward the corner by garcia
a good play to cut it off and garcia
with a two out single justin smoke
stands in the brewers need one more base
runner to have a chance
breaking ball is hammered into the
corner that is
a fair ball
and will bounce out of play and then
back into play for a double
and rbi double and now
the milwaukee brewers are one swing away
from
potentially tying this ball game
[Music]
here's one popped up left side hap is
there
breaks another bat and the cubs win this
ball game
a final of four to two